Chúng ta đã gửi chết rồi.
Cái gì vậy?
Mưa lưỡi kéo dài đã phá vừa hòn toàn lên cái đất đá.
Hồi cơ sật lời lúc này có thể up suốt.
Bất cứ lúc nào.
Ở cơ sửi lời lũi khô bất đàn bên trong.
Hồi em nhất là bụng lũi đất lắc, khánh hoa.
Lời đằng có đến hơn 2 chăm só phường.
Năm trong vụng lúc cơ cao đến rất cao.
Nhìn thấy bại vì thông ở nhà luôn,
nhìn ở nông,
khang ngay nó tạo lỡi vậy quá?
Các trường hợp từ vòng,
đều dấu sật lời đất,
lất tình, phọc, giọc, giọc, giọc, giọc,
Mưa lũi cũng gây sự của lưỡi đẹp trên dọc,
khiến bên còn hàng chăm nhìn hộ ra điện,
đặc biệt lúc hiện,
nhau nhất là tại đất lắc và ra lài.
Nếu lũi rất quán nhàng,
nhau khô rất cơ bị của lập hoàn toàn.
Nhưng người rất cơ cữ,
mà có những lời, ngập quá sâu,
nên em quá phức tạm,
lực lượng gử hộ cứ nạn vẫn chưa thể tiêu cận được.